ومشاهدينا بعيدا عن الاسلحه بعيده المدى
التي تنوي واشنطن تزويدك يبها فالدبابات
التي تسير على سكه الوصول الى اوكرانيا
اصبحت مهدده وبشكل علني المؤسسه الروسيه
الحكوميه لتطوير وانتاج وتصدير المنتجات
الصناعيه عاليه التقنيه روستخ اعلنت ان
دبابات اليوبارتو الالمانيه يمكن تدميرها
بواسطه المنظومات المضاده للدبابات
الروسيه مثل الكورنيت وصواريخ بيخر واتاكا
الجويه بالاضافه الى قذائف 125 ملم من
طرازمانجو
اوضحت ايضا ان دبابات على عكس الدبابات
الروسيه ليس لديها حمايه ديناميكيه
وبالتالي ليس لديها ما يحميها من الصواريخ
الروسيه فاخر واتاكا التي تستخدمها للقوات
الجويه الروسيه بنجاح لتدمير المركبات
المدرعه الاوكرانيه